all right so since the merger happened
with WWE and UFC the president of the
WWE said that now the UFC fighters that
have personalities and stuff they have
an Avenue to go to in WWE to prolong
their careers I mean certain ones do
that have yeah personalities that are
big stars they're not just going to take
like an undercard kid who gets cut and
put them in the WWE if they're retiring
you know like Amanda Nunes or you'll
hear Fighters talk about their bodies
getting broken down and they just can't
do it anymore oh and you think the WWE
is the answer I think it's fair to say
their bodies get more tore up than a UFC
fighter I think it's a good thing to say
I think a few of them a few outliers are
going to get there Kobe Covington could
do it I mean you have to have a
personality Sean Strickland Sean
O'Malley I think they do well agree yeah
Derek this would be great too yeah dude
Islam
[Laughter]
I want to come through would he be you
have that pallbear guide me like yes
Islam's like
what the hell is going on here foreign